à nouveau d'une période très
intéressante parce que c'est la période
des bons plans c'est la période de la
fin de l'année à la fin de l'année il ya
plein de bons points il ya plein de
promo pour venir vous permettre
d'acheter tous les produits vous voulez
de faire des cadeaux dans les meilleures
conditions leur situation un peu
particulière cette année je vais rien
vous apprendre avec effectivement la
crise du coc vie donc c'est bon pop avec
encore plus intéressant pour vous
permettre de garder de l'argent pour
aller acheter auprès de vos petits
commerçants
donc ça c'est vraiment cool l'ajustement
aujourd'hui ce que je vais vous faire
c'est que je vous présenter différents
bons plans de partenaires de marque
j'aime bien que j'ai sélectionné pour
vous permettre de faire des achats
malins de pouvoir renouveler votre
smartphone une honte pourquoi pas plein
d'objets ou alors de faire de très jolis
cadeaux et surtout de le faire dans les
meilleures conditions et aujourd'hui
c'est notamment une vidéo qui réalisé en
partenariat avec free lui alors et demi
je sais pas si vous connaissez si vous
en souvenez j'en ai déjà parlé
c est la marque qui a des boîtes jaunes
vraiment vous la connaîtrez très
facilement grâce à ces boîtes jaunes
alors il me l'a dit tiens de ce groupe
ce que tu vas faire une vidéo pour
parler des bons plans pour la fin
d'année
est ce que tu pourrais parler de nous et
resituer kirill me et présenter les
produits jeudi mais bien évidemment et
demi donc aujourd'hui ce que je vais
vous faire ce que je vais vous présenter
trois produits les ennemis on a le
rythme ici sourit 17 et on a le remy x50
5g parce que oui l'a5 jr est d'ailleurs
un tout c'est de commencer par ce
produit là ce produit là est vachement
intéressant pour la 5g parce que oui
vous le savez je vous apprends rien la
5g arrivait welcome to do ré mi fa mille
jeunes même si petit message là la 5g
est en train d'arriver
justement ce smartphone là il vient
vraiment s'inscrire là dedans comme
étant un smartphone qui est déjà prêt
pour la 5g et surtout un tarif très
intéressant parce que le rythme ix55
j'écoute en version 6 giga de ram plus
128 go de stockage 379 euros et si vous
trouvez au tarif de 279 euros
vous avez donc 100 euros de remise pour
un produit qui coûte quand même 3 79
points à la base autant vous dire c'est
vraiment cool parce rythmique 50 5 g il
n'a pas que ça comme qualité et aussi
plein d'autres qualités
vous avez notamment ici un grand écran
de 6 57 pouces avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 hertz ce qui
vous apportera plus de fluidité pour
venir naviguer sur internet et pour
venir jouer à tous vos jeux en plus ici
on a un processeur en milieu de gamme
c'est le stand ragona 7 165 g
j'ai pour gaming on a une grosse
batterie de 4200 millions période on a
de la recharge rapide 30 watts et vous
le voyez ici à l'arrière vous avez pas
moins de quatre caméras pour venir faire
toutes les photos qui vous font plaisir
à continuer ensuite avec un mode
smartphones de rim mis le riz mi6 alors
le rythme ici s'il est aussi très
intéressant vous avez si une
configuration de base 4 gigas de ram 64
giga de stockage il coûte normalement
229 euros est ici vous pouvez la voir à
189 euros
c'est vraiment super super super
intéressant vous allez retrouver ici un
grand écran de 6,5 pouces avec un taux
de rafraîchissement de 90 hertz donc
apportera aussi de la fluidité pour
jouer pour venir naviguer ça s'est très
très bien et surtout vous avez à
l'arrière pas moins de quatre caméras
tout ça à moins de 200 euros
le processeur c'est un médiathèque 7,1
et lioger 90 t 8 gigas de ram 128 go de
stockage vous avez de quoi mettre tous
vos souvenirs toutes vos photos tout ce
que vous voulez à l'intérieur et ce qui
est bien en plus là dessus si vous avez
une grosse batterie de 4300 milles
antérieur et de la recharge rapide 30
watts je trouve plutôt pas mal et super
bien positionnés à moins de 100 euros à
189 euros pour être très précis ces
oeuvres la trouverez chez amazon et
cdiscount est une fois de plus je vous
lis tous les liens en bas dans la
description a continué ensuite avec
celui là c'est le readme sept pros alors
leurs ennemis 7 pro il est aussi
vachement bien via parle à mon petit
lapin en plus d'avoir un capteur
d'empreintes digitales situé sous
l'écran vous avez sur smartphone surtout
avec une très très grosse capacité de
recharge
ici vous avez de la superba 65 watts
vous permet de le recharger de 0 à 13 %
en 5 minutes et de 0 à 100 % seulement
34 minutes
autant vous dire que ça d'habitude ça va
très très très vite en plus si vous avez
un écran de 6 5 pouces super amoled un
processeur milieu de gamme c'est le
snapdragon 720 g 8 gigas de ram 256 go
de stockage et une grosse batterie de
4500 millions perrin chasse par phone
qui est disponible au tarif de 329 euros
normalement cloud touch à 299 euros chez
cdiscount et amazon une fois de plus les
liens sont dans la description j'ai
plein de bons plans que je vous ai
sélectionné on va commencer par les
smartphones y aura pas que du smartphone
y aura plein de choses intéressantes on
va faire un tour du côté de chez samsung
alors sa mission de vous savez on sorti
beaucoup de produits cette année ayant
mangé trouvé vraiment
la sonde et qui je pense pourrait vous
intéresser surtout qu'à une offre en ce
moment c'est le samsung galaxy à 51 je
vous mets les liens des tests que j'ai
fait sur les smartphones dont je vous
parle aujourd'hui dans la description
pour avoir plus d'information plus tous
les liens si vous souhaitez les acheter
profiter de ses bons plans il existe
deux versions du samsung galaxy à 51
soit une version 4g sont une version 5 g
si vous ne pensez pas aller sur un
abonnement 5 g l'année prochaine quand
ils seront enfin disponibles en france
en tout cas
eh bien il va son casier pas être
vraiment intéressante surtout qu'elle
coûte 299 euros à moins de 300 euros
vous avez un smartphone qui vachement
intéressant chez samsung contre la
version 5 g qui coûte 100 euros de plus
à 399 euros via le smartphone qui m'a
beaucoup d'intérêt cette année chez
samsung j'ai testé à new york en début
d'année c'est le samsung galaxy ace d'un
ultra ultra avec ce qui est le mieux en
terme de photos aujourd'hui chez samsung
vous avez l'esprit une fois sans france
as watson qui est assez intéressant et
qu'il est évidemment aussi un smartphone
5 g je vous renvoie une fois de plus à
ma vidéo pour tout savoir sur ce
smartphone mais il est très cool et puis
le smartphone qui m'a beaucoup plu aussi
c'est le samsung galaxy z flip le nom
est un peu à coucher dehors mais le
format est vachement cool le fait
d'avoir un smartphone que vous pouvez
plier en deux pour le rond plus petit
moi j'ai vraiment adoré le premier
smartphone très cool expérience
vachement bien on reste dans l' ultra
premium à dacca smart qui coûte quand
même mille 559 euros c'est pas donné
mais on a vraiment aujourd'hui un
smartphone d'exception donc si vous
souhaitez vous faire plaisir
si vous avez les moyens de faire et bien
c'est vraiment un très joli produit en
faire un tour du côté de chez nous parce
que on peut aussi bien bossé cette année
avec notamment une gamme finepix
renouvelée et un plateau que j'ai trouvé
vachement bien dans la gamme finepix
c'est le aux pauvres filles ii x2 pro
super smartphone belle finition très bel
écran très bien maîtrisé c'est le
flagship aujourd'hui chez au pot il a
baissé légèrement vous pouvez trouver 1
949 au lieu de 1199 ça reste quand même
une somme mais qui dit smartphone
d'exception dit à tout de suite assez
élevé il ya le produit dont je vous ai
parlé il ya pas très longtemps c'est le
au port et nos quatre pros on va
continuer à parler dans les temps à
venir de cette gamme de au pot le au
port et de 4 pro il est vachement bien
parce que déjà il est très fin sur la
prise en main très joli design il est
vraiment axé sur la vidéo avec une super
stabilisation vous avez de la recharge
très rapide
en 65 watts c'est la superbe look et
c'est un smartphone qui est 5 g on reste
quand même dans le très haut de gamme là
dessus on est à 799 euros mais c'est un
très joli smartphones et cette année aux
poux est sorti aussi une très jolie
gamme
il ya également le pauvre âge cela monde
connecté doc ou dont on parlera d'ici
quelques jours et vous le savez il faut
également venir protéger vos smartphones
avec des coques de protection ou tout
accessoire protection justement vos
partenaires et nos chine fait le black
friday du 19 novembre au 2 décembre
vous avez de 10 à 60 % de remise sur
l'île de rhinau chine et 10% de remise
supplémentaire avec le code greu 2020
vous hamid évidemment tous les liens en
bas dans la description chaline auch il
vous avez une large gamme notamment des
coques solide suite hunter et enter vous
avez également une collection fortnight
si vous aimez l'espace vous avez toute
une collection cosmos approuvé par la
nasa
si vous préférez la sobriété vous avez
également des soli de suite soit tout
noir soit également comme ça avec un
effet carbone si vous souhaitez voir le
dos de votre smartphone vous avez
l'écrasent garde sur lequel vous y
retrouver uniquement les boutons qui
vont venir protéger les quatre coins de
votre smartphone et si vous voulez plus
de décoration et bien vous avez les
modes enix ou là vous allez pouvoir
jouer sur différentes couleurs le rouge
le violet le noir vous avez énormément
de choix vous invite à aller faire un
tour sur le site de rhinau chine il
voudrait devenir les customiser en
enlevant sept parties à l'intérieur on
la change en l'interchange en faisant ce
que vous voulez mais vous avez bien plus
que sa chérie nos sud avec des
protections d'écran pour venir vous
protégez votre smartphone contre tous
les chocs
il y en a pour tout le monde tous les
smartphones récents que ce soit tous les
iphone vous pouvez également bien
protéger vos apple watch vos airpod et
beaucoup de smartphones android
sérinophile vous avez également des
accessoires et notamment voyez ici un
câble lightning extrêmement résistant et
qui vous accompagnera dans toutes vos
aventures
j'aime beaucoup très bien il ya
également assassin's creed vous avez
également marc gouton il ya beaucoup de
possibilités de personnalisation chéri
nos chine si vous n'avez jamais testé
rhino schild est bien vu les tarifs en
ce moment qui le pratique pour black
friday je pense que ça vaut vraiment le
coup et en plus de ça des 50 euros de
commande et bien vous avez les frais de
port qui vous sont offertes c'est le
moment ou jamais de venir penser à
protéger son smartphone au meilleur coût
il ya d'autres produits qui sont très
intéressants si également du côté de
chez xiaomi notamment smartphones que
j'ai testé ya pas longtemps que j'ai
beaucoup peiné c'est le mythe
c'était prompt souvenez-vous en début
d'année shiomi avait augmenté ses tarifs
avec sa gamme midi ce midi ce projet
j'ai adoré le midi seront un peu moins
de 1000 euros très cher par rapport à se
trouver habituellement chez chuo mise
par contre on avait un rendu photo
incroyable superbe écran expérience
audio top smartphone extrêmement
performant le top
alors si vous ne souhaitez pas mettre un
peu moins de 1000 euros dans ce
smartphone aujourd'hui
eh bien vous avez le lui disent tu es
pro qui va commencer le meilleur du
milices pro 1 tarifs plus accessibles
vous n'irez pas aussi loin interne photo
vous n'irez pas aussi loin dans
l'expérience par contre vous avez un
smartphone qui coûte quand même 400
euros - et c'est non négligeable autre
produit intéressant du côté de chez chuo
me vous allez leur ennemi note neuf pros
le nom est un peu long mais le
smartphone est intéressant c'est un
smartphone qui coûte un peu moins de 200
euros pour un peu moins de 200 euros
vous avez quatre caméras
même si le capteur principal et 64
mégapixels sera celui qui fera vraiment
le meilleur boulot il a le processeur
milieu de gamme le snapdragon 720 jaequi
vraiment très bon dans cette gamme de
prix là et il a une très grosse batterie
de 5000 20 millions paiera je vous
emmène maintenant chez apple et les
produits d'apple ont une valeur
résiduelle qui reste assez hot ça veut
dire que même dans le temps les prix ne
baissent pas beaucoup chez apple ils
gardent une vraie valeur sur le marché
sont des produits de qualité bien finie
il faut et b à ios l'expérience moi je
les aime beaucoup j'aime beaucoup de
produits j'aime beaucoup les cocistes
elle
j'en ai déjà parlé et je continue à vous
en parler d'autant plus que cette année
apple gentille pas moins de cinq
smartphones est une première dans leur
histoire
alors moi j'ai sélectionné deux produits
aimé que je trouve vraiment cool et déjà
l'iphone douce pro est sorti cette année
qui est un excellent produit super bons
produits vous en ai déjà parlé mais je
trouve quand même un peu cher ce que je
peux vous conseiller de faire c'est
d'aller sur l'iphone 11 pro iphone de
l'année dernière qui reste extrêmement
actuelle et qui répondra à quasiment
tous vos usages qui est super bon en
photo ou en vidéo qui est très bonne
autonomie qui est très bon niveau
l'expérience logiciel c'est un super
smartphone je peux vous conseiller
d'aller jeter un coup d'oeil du côté du
reconditionnés parce que je pense que
c'est là que vous trouverez moins cher
il n'est plus au catalogue d'apple pour
retrouver l'iphone 11 uniquement au
catalogue d'apple l'iphone on se prend
n'y est plus pour le trouver chez notre
vendeur en neuf mais je pense que je
regardais en reconditionnés avec
certains cycles propose des garanties 24
mois ça peut être bien d'ailleurs je
vous en parle dans quelques jours dont
vous invite à venir vous abonner pour
tout savoir vous verrez c'est très
intéressant reconditionnés chapple ça
vaut vraiment le coup donc ça c'est déjà
bien est ce que je peux vous conseiller
également celles d'aliments l'iphone est
sorti cette année
le design est un peu school mais par
contre il est vraiment bien super
performances de la puce à 13 bionic est
vraiment très très bonne vous avez un
seul capteur à l'arrière mais par contre
vous avez exactement le même capteur que
vous avez sur l'iphone onze pros on se
prend max
il est super bon fait super photo
autonomie est bonne le smartphone est
très cool alors il ya un smartphone qui
coule aussi en photo c'est le pixel 5
pixels 5 vous en parle dans quelques
jours il ya un produit j'aime beaucoup
aussi que j'utilise tous les jours chez
moi c'est le nest max alors le nez stone
max vous en ai déjà parlé il ya un petit
moment c'est pas un produit qui est
nouveau c'est comme une enceinte google
avec un écran un écran une caméra qui va
vous aider aussi pour pouvoir
communiquer avec votre famille s'il vous
avait plusieurs des stones match entre
chez vous êtes un autre membre de votre
famille chez lui et bien vous pour
communiquer très facilement vous permet
de faire revivre toutes vos photos de
les faire défiler de voir votre agenda
de voir la météo de pouvoir commander ce
que vous voulez de voir des recettes le
produit je trouve superbe
chez moi il est dans la cuisine cuisine
salon ouvert et je peux vous assurer que
j'utilise tout le temps le destin mac
c'est une promo intéressante qui
écoutait quand même 2 129 à 199 et on
trouve en ce moment à 169 euros 99
si vous aimez la maison connectée si
vous voulez avoir une maison connectée
pour baldas comme max il est super alors
justement on de partir un peu plus loin
sur la maison connectée
je vous conseille également les produits
de chez philips ue sur les éclairages la
voyait au la lumière l'arrière vous avez
un you man bas j'ai toute la maison qui
équipé en poule collecter de philips et
j'adore ça c'est vraiment superbe
ça reste un petit budget si vous voulez
acheter les ampoules et tous connectés
ce que je vous conseille sadc déjà que
le starter kit kit de démarrage
vous allez avoir un pont vous allez
connectés et qui vous servira de base
chez vous et ensuite de pouvoir ajouter
des ampoules del godet striffler quant à
tout ce que vous voulez
la gamme est extrêmement large il ya des
lampes ya tout j'aime beaucoup ton mais
les lionnes fait plus en bas dans la
description aux produits super
intéressant je voudrais parler ya un
petit moment pour tous les fans de
baladeurs extérieur qui vont faire du
trail qui partent en montagne qui vont
faire de l' escalade
c'est le smartphone de crosse comme l'un
des smartphones de crosse cole c'est le
très correct 4,6 aujourd'hui leur
smartphone le plus haut de gamme grand
public qui résiste au froid qui résiste
aux coups qui peut aller sous l'eau
j'ai eu plein de belles mises à jour le
smartphone est vraiment super je les
tester également à new york a remis deux
dents en an et demi deux ans mais tous
deux ans et il est vraiment intéressant
attention il est vraiment dédié aux
personnes qui vont faire de la dore ou
qui sont maladroits qui casse tout le
temps à un smartphone ou si vous bossez
d'ennui btp dans les chantiers que votre
smartphone est toujours malmené et bien
ce smartphone live vraiment fait pour
vous il reste quand même un certain
budget lui coûte quand même aujourd'hui
un peu moins de 700 euros et 699 euros
avec 90 mais il est vraiment bien et
pour tous ses usages
croyez-moi il vous rendra vraiment de
grands services on va faire un tour
maintenant de voter de chez huawei alors
moi ou et c'est une marque que vous
connaissez j'en ai déjà beaucoup parler
moi je garde un smartphone en tête cet
allié qui m'a beaucoup plu chez ba ouai
c'est le p 40 pro alors il ya eu
plusieurs smartphones chez huawei
messieurs je trouve intéressant pour la
photo une fois de plus au wawel ne fait
aucune concession au niveau des
appareils en termes de qualité hardware
au niveau de la photo 5 très très très
bel appareil est une fois de plus je
vous renvoie mais vidéo test pour venir
le voir
il coûtait 1099 euros et vous pouvez le
trouver en ce moment 1 949 euros 99
alors attention attention ici c'est un
smartphone pour les utilisateurs avertis
et pour les personnes qui n'utilisent
pas les 110 google pour les personnes
qui potentiellement n'aime pas google ou
qui veulent une alternative parce que
oui vous êtes effectivement sur un
android ici mais vous n'avez pas le
plextor pas d'applications google
que dalle rien du tout vous avez la
galerie la galerie cette étape
d'application de huawei qui se développe
de plus en plus avec pleins
d'applications vous allez également
pétales search vous permettra de trouver
toutes les applications qui ne sont pas
encore aujourd'hui référencés dans la
gare et vous en ai déjà parlé tout ça
marche très bien mais une fois de plus
si vous utilisez le service google si
vous aimez google
ce smartphone n'était pas fait pour vous
si vous êtes au contraire quelqu'un qui
n'aime pas particulièrement google et
qui n'utilisent pas les services google
et bien ça peut être une alternative
très intéressante pour vous alors on va
continuer avec au nord au nord qui fait
partie du groupe
huawei et qui dans les smartphones que
je vous présente et n'ont pas non plus
le plextor on la galerie il ya les
honneurs 10 x lite dont je vous ai parlé
il ya très peu de temps qu'une promo
intéressante
normalement il à 229 euros 90 là vous
trouverez à 199 euros 90 plutôt bien sur
le site des eaux nord il ya également le
haut noir 9
ah bon je vous ai déjà parlé qui coûtait
149 euros 90 et vous peut trouver à 129
euros 90 fois de plus je vous invite
tous les liens en bas par la description
des chiens au nord il ya un autre
produit qui coule on faisait pareil
cette année et bien sûr le magic book là
le majin 14 une super pro
dessus il est vachement intéressant il
coûtait normalement 749 euros 90 c à
vous trouver à 649 90 on a 100 euros de
moi plutôt bien pour une bonne machine
polyvalente qui vous servira surtout
pour faire de la petite bureautique
familiale de la prise de notes pour
aller regarder les séries sur internet
pour aller faire vos e-mails vous
n'allez pas faire de la 3d relief vous
n'avez pas faire du montage vidéo
mais pour ces usages là et bien croyez
moi vous avez vraiment vraiment de quoi
faire alors maintenant à faire faire un
tour du côté de l'audio moi j'utilise
depuis un bon moment un casque sony cwh
nissan 3
j'en ai déjà parlé là j'ai testé il ya
très peu de temps leur dernier casque
c'est le sony w/h milices al qadr alors
pour l'avoir testé je trouve bien il ya
une évolution effectivement par rapport
au public 5,3 mais je trouve que
l'évolution n est pas suffisamment
significatifs donc je vous conseille
aujourd'hui d'aller acheter ce w/h
melixon 3 qui est pour moi une des
références si ce n'est la référence en
termes de réduction de bruit active en
terme de qualité pour le casque grand
public c'est un casque et coûté un peu
moins de 400 euros à la base qui
aujourd'hui a baissé parce que le
mythique salle iv est sorti que vous
pouvez trouver au tarif de 299 euros et
en ce moment vous le problème à 249
euros 99 c'est vraiment super bien j'ai
tout quand on sait que la musique c'est
le 4 août aujourd'hui un peu 24 100
euros à 360 1999 à lorient c'est notre
casque que j'aime beaucoup
j'ai testé en début d'année également
nos gars proches beaucoup la note cette
année voyez malgré le confinement et
guess un casque de buzz c'est le lc 700
réduction brouille actif très bonne
qualité également applications pour
l'utiliser un peu le même système que se
retrouve avec le test que le soli il est
en promo également ils étaient 1 399 199
vous pouvez trouver à 299 euros 99 pas
plus je veux tous les liens en bas dans
la description en faire le tour
maintenant de vous défier asus alors
asus j'aime beaucoup c'est une marque
qui innove qui est intéressante une
marque taïwanaise et surtout se sentir
smartphones qui est vraiment bien c'est
la troisième version c'est le rock folk
on à le rendre fou nous trouvons cette
année qui est une vraie machine de
compet pour le gaming c'est un
smartphone de gaming les tester jeu-là
d'orge peuvent très bien vous avez plein
d'accessoires
c'est pas un smartphone qui est pas très
cher coûte à ses chiens leurs
accessoires également mais par contre en
terme d'expérience si vous aimez jouer
sur votre smartphone
eh bien vous ferait vraiment plaisir il
est très puissant il coûtait 999 euros
et vous trouvez à 100 euros de moins
899 euros une fois de plus les liens
sont dans la description aux premiers
qui est bien chez asus c'est le zèle
phone 7 prônant le jeune soit 7 pro il
est un petit peu vous il installe des
caméras flic est très intéressant qui
pourra potentiellement vous correspondre
en fonction de vous et de vos usages
vous permet d'avoir quand même pas moins
de trois caméras en selle firefox mêmes
modules qui bascule vous allez voir
trois caméras en cf3 caméra à l'arrière
le smartphone est assez intéressant
surtout vous avez un grand écran qui est
bègue âgées sans encoches centre ou sans
but sans notes sans rien du tout ça
j'aime bien l'inconvénient c'est que le
smartphone est un peu lourd à cause du
mécanisme la caméra et à cause du moteur
mais par contre l'expérience est
vraiment intéressante c'est un
smartphone qui écoutait 799 euros et
vous pouvez trouver 1 699 euros alors là
tant à faire un tour du côté de chez
microsoft microsoft qui a sorti ya pas
très longtemps la surface laptop gook
j'ai déjà testé je trouve très bien
y'a pas de promo le produit est neuf
mais si vous voulez aller faire un tour
du côté de chez microsoft et bien c'est
un super ordinateur très bien
positionnés et puis il ya un produit qui
est vachement bien qui est sorti l'année
dernière dans le prix best c'est la
surface pro7 la surface pro7 elle
coûtait 1000 369 euros en version 8
gigas de ram plus 256 go de stockage et
vous la trouvez à -25% à 1026 0,75 alors
notre produit que j'aime bien c'est one
plus one place étant de plus en plus sa
gamme là vous avez eu beaucoup de
produits notamment la one + nom de la
gamme north qui est sorti qui s'étend
également à l'eau si mais moi je vais
pas pour parler de la gamme dehors parce
que pour le 'black friday' wyplosz vous
propose moins 150 euros de remise sur
son one + 8 des taux bien au lieu de 649
euros ça nous propose à 499 euros
autant vous dire que tout appel 100
euros de plus que les whites norns et on
n'a pas du tout ici à même fiche
technique plutôt bien intéressant je
pense que pour l'occasion du black
friday sur le stick dow jones
ça vaut le coup et enfin on va parler
maintenant caméra d'action a parlé go
pro et j'ai testé la dernière mot pro
iront 9 blacks il ya quelques mois
ego prend une politique qui est assez
intéressante ils veulent un petit peu
emmener les gens se dire essayer les
services de go pro a et c est qu un
abonnement ce qui fait qu'en fait 7 09
black qui coûte tout seul 479 en 99 on
peut trouver en promo attal 129 euros 99
et bien si vous l'achetez avec des
accessoires et qu'en plus ils vous
offrent un an au service de groupes
eh bien vous l'a payé 379 198 300 euros
- donc vous achetez la gopro accessoires
et vous avez un abonnement offert ça
vous coûte 100 euros de moins qu'une
banque ou tout seul comme quand ils
veulent vraiment mettre le paquet là
dessus donc moi que ça vaut le coup si
vous voulez acheter une belle caméra
d'action il faut mettre en garde et que
le tarif auquel est vendu ce pack là et
bien c'est le prix de la gopro 08 black
de l'année dernière autant vous dire que
là franchement ça vaut le coup d'aller
sur l'album black
voilà pour toutes ces offres ça fait une
vidéo un petit peu longue mais je
voulais vraiment vous donner cette
sélection de fin d'année il ya encore
plein d'autres produits dont je vous ai
pas parlé qui sont super intéressant
mais il a fallu faire des choix parce
que voyez on est déjà une vidéo qui dure
un petit peu longtemps j'avoue me dire
vous quels sont les produits qui
pourraient potentiellement vous
intéresser ce qu'elle ait produit vous
ai cités que vous avez déjà acheté est
ce qu'elle est chose que vous auriez
envie d'acquérir et est ce que cette
vidéo vous aura et des marques il m'a
tout ça en bas mais évidemment en
commentaire talent on se retrouve très
rapidement pour continuer à parler
d'elle parce qu'en ce moment il ya
tellement de choses qu'on ne s'arrête
plus ou beaucoup d'amour a très vite
tels que william fraîchement yuja wang
jun santana
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]